hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the proc chess festival
it's a game from the masters division we
mentioned during the livestream
yesterday by the way thank you all for
joining the livestream and also for
joining my first first in a long time
chess arena unli chess before we get
into this game adjust like to
congratulate the winners once again so
congratulations to assuage the dark
vortex double-oh-seven and to zebedee
videos for winning top three places in
yesterday's tournament and as you can
see 2327 players applied and played in
the tournament so that's just insane
since you know there were no money
prizes or anything like that it was
purely for honor I swam I definitely
congratulations and hopefully as it will
become this is now a weekly event so for
those who are saying that you didn't
know it was gonna happen or when it was
most likely next Friday also at 6 6 p.m.
Central European Time yeah you should
definitely be there it's gonna be really
awesome but yeah we're gonna talk about
that and if something changes a bit more
afterwards now let's get back to this
game so like I said from the masters
division of the proc chess festival it's
a templayer round-robin
so everyone faces off against everyone
the tournament was organized by a nova
board chess club and yeah it's just a
wonderful event now this game is nikita
be cuba vs young shift of Duda and we're
gonna talk about who also played and
what were the results after the game but
it's it's a really nice game so I do
hope you enjoy it without further ado
let's check out the game v2 bob has the
white pieces and he opens with E for now
we have c5 the Sicilian defense Knight
to f3 d6 we have d4 see captures knife
captures in mountain Knight to f6 Knight
to c3 and of course a 6 we have denied
Earth on the board white was for a for
preventing black from expanding would be
5 and preparing a5 in the future we have
g6 black now it decides the Finca to the
bishop and developed this way Bishop to
e2 by white Bishop to g7 and now just
Bishop to e3 preparing Queen to d2
we have Knight to c6 challenging white
center central knight on d4
both players castle and here we have
Queen to d2 so it's um it's it's quite
similar as you know you would have for
example in a dragon but it's it's a
combination of a over dragon with a six
where of course white is not interested
in castling queenside as a black would
already have have a target in there so
here of course the white would
definitely want to play at some point
Bishop to h6 you have this very nice
batter you wanna trade off Black's dark
square Bishop and it's a fairly non line
card I can play that against top ten we
have in last year in 2018 in the world
rapid championship in sunk Peter Burke
where Bishop to d7 was played by
artemiev but here we have the immediate
Knight captures on d4 by Duda and okay
Bishop captures now the bishop is no
longer able to go for this plan Bishop
to e6 and now if you go back with Bishop
to e3 then black can just continue or
look to c8 and if you do this then let's
say you even exchange the queen is not
gonna be able to do much there you don't
have any other pieces to help the Queen
out with the attack just Queen b6 ah
nicely and nice to developmental move
and you don't have any backup from your
from your pieces although although the
Queen is placed fairly nicely so here we
have a five just you know a nice bone
completely blocking of blacks Queen side
development sorry about that
where you could perhaps put a bishop on
b6 you could go Knight a four to b6 also
a nice square for the knight but yeah
it's it's it's an interesting idea here
rook to see it was played and now we
have looked a for a very nice rook lift
and this is in fact a new move in this
position so V to have came very much
prepared also a non move here was rook F
to D one this is what Michael Adams
played against nippon-ichi in the 2017
London chess classic but neppo actually
won that won that game but here look
today for seems to be an improvement by
the cube of so let's see let's see what
happens rook the before is the idea
pressuring the Queen side as the point
here very nicely blocks it
we have rook the c6 black has ideas of
b5 in the future so if a capture some b6
and Poisson
the rook and queen are ready to control
the square and also when the Queen moves
the other row can come over to the C
file and the rooks will be nicely
doubled up we have f4 by white and now
comes Queen to d7 rook the b4s plans as
the Queen is no longer attacking the a5
pawn just pressuring that b7 pawn and
here we have rook F to ca to W up
Bishop to d3 now just nicely controlling
both the C to pawn ended the e4 pawn as
if the knight moves the seat upon
becomes a target with Bishop to c4 black
now wants to trade off the light square
bishop so he can now continue his
expansion in the center h3 just you know
improving the position taking away the
g4 Square from the Black Knight Bishop
captures and here Queen captures on d 3c
captures on d3 also seems like like a
very nice move just you know removes
that c2 pawn from being ever a target if
the knight moves and also just very
nicely defense d4 pawn but Vic YouGov
has a different idea he was Queen
captures on d1 d3 and now II five ok
black very nicely expanded their White
has to react Bishop to e3 pawn captures
the bishop captures and now well this is
now pretty much a backwards upon you it
could become a target for example if
ruby d1 is played so you don't want to
keep it there here black takes this
opportunity to go between the c7 he
attacks the a5 pawn and white just
replies that it this would came to h1 he
doesn't want to have his King on this
dark square diagonal black still has the
Queen black still has the dark square
Bishop and you know you should always
play King to h1 if you play the Sicilian
mm no I mean your things can always go
wrong if you keep it on g1 and black
still has a dark square Bishop and a
queen you always could you constantly
have to keep an eye on every and any
check possible because it could go you
know in your opponent's favor so here
you could capture but then you lose the
b7 pawn here black decided for b5 and
okay we have a capture some basic Samba
Sun the Rope is now in place rook
captures with rook captures Queen
captures and here Bishop captures and b6
White is now up upon preparing a 5 which
would
much nicely cemented that bishop on d6
and also if if I was played the knight
has to move there will be a lot of
pressure against the f7 pawn the Queen
can come to d5 black will have to defend
but here indeed Knights the e8 would be
the best course of action for black just
getting the knight out of the way if I
would be played and then you might
capture on b2 and the game continues 95
and so on and so on but here Duda
decided he will not be you know down
material for a very long time and here
he decided he decided that the b2 point
is not not a poisoned pawn and he
grabbed it but feel free to pause the
video here and try to continue this game
for white how does the white approach
this position I'll give you a couple of
seconds for you to decide for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
finder of you know viable plans for
white and for those who just want to
enjoy the show Knight to d5 this is the
idea and you have to realize that well
the pawn should not be captured by the
Queen or by the rope but it's
interesting we should explore some
options here for black for example if
Queen captures then it just doesn't work
Knight captures Bishop captures as black
was in check Queen captures rook
captures now we just pick up the bishop
and white is up uh white is up a piece
so even the passed pawn will not will
not prove to be very helpful you know in
in helping black defend also an idea is
Knight captures on d5 immediately then
you get Queen captures and after let's
say King to h8 as the f7 pawn is under
attack as you do want to win back this
one let's the King h8 now Queen captures
and black
well black black is just worse here you
will have to defend you can never leave
the back rank there there are plenty of
threats here so it would definitely go
in White's favor so here Duda tried a
different idea he played rook characters
on c2 immediately and here we have a
very important moment in the game once
again pause the video here and try to
find the winning move for white the the
g2 pawn is under attack but you know you
know keep that in mind I'll give you a
couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are a really quick
winner of games that that can be quickly
won and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show in the game we to go
played Bishop to a3 which is a winning
move but there is a well there is a much
more forcing line if you found Knight
captures on f6 with check then you
really know how to handle your business
because after Bishop captures you get E
5 now and now of course you see that the
Queen cannot capture because the Queen
has to keep an eye on the rook here if
you capture with the bishop then you
just get Bishop captures between
characters and Queen captures here why
this upper roof and if you don't now if
you move the bishop back let's say we go
back up g7 then you get e 6 now really
black is in trouble after F captures now
again Bishop to e5 and there's not all
that much you can do the Queen threatens
to come up there after Bishop captures
you will just get Queen d8 check King g7
and Queen to f8 will be checkmate
so this was one possibility for V to
have to continue this attack after this
rook captures and C to move but he
played a different line he played Bishop
to e3 harassing the Queen here and now
you can either capture and lose the rook
here or you can play what Duda played
here that's queen to b5 okay if you
capture my rook I will capture rook on
f1 that's undefended and you don't want
to allow that so here we could go just
played Knight captures on f6 Bishop
captures we have Queen captures pawn
captures and now rook captures on f6 so
all in all do that is now just down down
a piece and that there's no wait there's
no way to have any compensation for it
here he tried b4 there's I mean you will
not be able to save it up on either way
so here he decides to give it 4 for the
e4 pawn we have bushel captures rook to
c4 not immediately first rook to c1
check King to h2 and normally not look
to see for going after the bishop and
the pawn ones on a light square ones on
a dark square so you will win at least
one of those we have looked the b6 and
not rook chapters on e4 so here we have
this endgame where white is upper bishop
but black is up upon and black is just
gonna play
you know just a bunker defense and it's
up to white to prove that he can he can
win this so first we have Bishop to c3
why not threaten checkmate immediately
rook the rook to b8 would force
checkmate you do have to defend we have
rook to e8 and now Bush up to f6 not
allowing black to expand here black
still has to keep an eye on the
background weaknesses the rook can never
leave the back rank we have h6 hoping to
put g5 so here white just prevents g5
you don't want to allow it with h4 king
- h7 and now comes Luke
rook to d6 just you know passing the
move to black and here if black try
something like h5 it's not gonna not
gonna work for example Luke d8 now
forces an exchange of rooks because
either you move the rook and you are
checkmated or captures captures and now
even if you try something you know maybe
to push g5 somehow you will never be
able to push it because the pawn and
Bishop just create a barrier and then
the King can just approach the position
start picking up pawns and it's game
over
so here do that try the different
approach he tried rook to e4 but it
doesn't help here okay if you go for
this checkmate idea immediately then
black can push g5 but after you know
some pawns are exchanged here he's been
walking to g6 and he can keep on
creating problems for white so here
every two book did not want to allow
this he played after this rook to e4
move
we have g3 just you know passing to move
back to black preparing to bring the
King in deeper into the game here do the
play group to e2 check we have King to
g1 and now rook to e3 preparing to pick
up the g3 pawn but here which you have
said no problem
rooftop d8 he threatened checkmate who
have g5 creating some room for the king
and now once again feel free to pause
the video but only briefly and you know
continue the game for white I know that
you didn't even have to pause it to see
it of course the movies h5 you take away
the g6 square from the black king now
this the pawn controlled g6 the bishop
controls g7 and there is no defense
against rook 2h8 checkmate or is there
well here rook captures on g3 was played
with
King to f2 and now g4 by Duda this is
just this is my favorite movie in the
entire game this is g4 move by do that
some of you would think that he's just
you know trolling he he wants to keep
the game going or maybe you know there
were some spectators and he wanted to
surprise them by allowing a nice
checkmate on the board but actually if
you just captured the rook then it's
stalemate so although you know chances
are very unlike it's very unlikely that
we Cuba would fall for such a trap but
you know you always have to try just
play g4 and whatever happens happens
you're getting checkmated and in the
next move but one in a thousand or maybe
1 in 10,000 games you know sometimes
your opponent will look that way he will
see ok that's a free rook and then you
know whoa it's still mate but not in
this game here after g4 nikita video
just played rook to h8 this was
checkmate and you know it's now like I
said it's not very often that you will
see a checkmate on the board between two
2700 plus grandmasters but here you have
one such checkmate
an excellent victory by nikita v cuba
who also won this tournament and this
was a game from round seven so not a
game from the final round
I believe he drew his game in the final
round but I did prepare the final
standings just so you can see who played
here and what were the results so there
you have it in first place from the
practice festival masters tournament
with five and a half points in akita
with cuba then four players with five
points video Gujarati who won his game
in the final round but it was not enough
to claim first place around for voyeur
shengshi stuff Duda and Boris Gelfand
with five points maybe we were gonna
show a few games where Boris Gelfand if
we if we find some nice photos of Boris
similar Shanklin with four and a half
den with four points spent alla
harikrishna Richard Report and David
Navarro and with victrolas michka
with three other nine so as you can see
was an extremely fierce tournament no
one has like seven seven hundred nine or
seven and a half hour nine so everything
is there anyone could have taken this
tournament you know definitely a nice
event and everyone played against
everyone so you know there were no
surprises all right chef that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I haven't been
you know I wasn't able to catch a lot of
games from the practice festival so Hugh
if you have any favorites do put a link
in the description below I will check it
out and yeah I would like to thank Kevin
Thurber Pedro Henrique Hollister
Norman booray John gear and James
Norwood for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thankful for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content and so on and we have an
excellent rest of your Saturday and once
again congratulations to the winners of
the the first target Metro Arena in a
long time thank you all and I will see
you soon